let's talk tv news with our good friend
vanessa lachey yes the boss lady of ncis
hawaii has already wrapped filming
season one and vanessa told et she is
feeling nothing but gratitude especially
for her hubby nick lachey
so we just moved all of our furniture
from the mainland to hawaii and i'm not
there
so super dad who's already watching all
three kids is now also moving our entire
house by himself
he's pretty incredible while nick's
holding things down at home vanessa is
gearing up for the ncis hawaii season
finale on monday the show is tv's number
one new drama on broadcast and we'll be
back for season two in the fall i'm
exactly where i'm supposed to be and to
be the first female lead of the ncis
franchise is such an honor
and from gayle king to wayne brady the
red carpet celebrating paramount and
cbs's new and returning shows was filled
with stars and it was a star trek
reunion with three of the current
captains this is my first time doing
something
with the star trek captains so that's
just exciting to me i said hello to
patrick earlier and samiko both of whom
are very lovely do you wish you were a
captain i left school at 15. if i can do
it you can do it well get ready to say
goodbye to riverdale the show's seventh
season on the cw will officially be its
last all great things have to come to an
end um and i and i feel good about it
we're in this together it's gonna be
really hard to say goodbye to archie
to riverdale we've created so many
memories on the show so it's going to be
hard
[Music]
you